>> WELCOME TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
JUSTICE IN AMERICA.
I AM JUDGE JEANINE SHAPIRO IN
FOR SEAN.
BUT TONIGHT START WITH THE
ECONOMY.
TAXES, SPENDING, AND THE DEFICIT
ARE ALL AT RECORD LEVELS.
YOUR PAYCHECKS ARE NOW WORTH
LESS THAN EVER.
A WHOPPING 5% IN MAY.
MEATS, FRUITS, VEGETABLES, LOW
LUMBER.
IT'S ALL MORE EXPENSIVE.
GAS IS UP 56% OVER LAST YEAR.
THIS IS A CRISIS.
IN A BRAND-NEW AXIAL FOCUS
GROUP, ONLY 3 OUT OF 13 VOTERS
SAID THEY FELT THE U.S. ECONOMY
IS BOOMING WHILE MOST FEARED AND
IMPENDING COLLAPSE BE OF THE
GROUP IS ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT AND BLAMED THE
GOVERNMENT FOR SO MANY PEOPLE
OUT OF WORK.
"NEARLY ALL OF THE VOTERS
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR JOBS BECAUSE THEY
MAKE MORE FROM CLAIMING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS."
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ECONOMY IS
JUST ONE OF THE MANY CRISIS ON
UNFOLDING.
TWO IRANIAN WARSHIPS ARE SAILING
ACROSS THE ATLANTIC.
THEY ARE LIKELY HEADED TO
VENEZUELA.
TO REPORTEDLY DELIVER SEVEN FAST
ATTACK SHIPS THAT COULD BE USED
TO USED TO INTERRUPT KEY
AMERICAN SUPPLY ROUTES ALONG THE
PANAMA CANAL.
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS ANY PLANS TO
STOP THIS OR ANY POTENTIAL ARMS
DEAL.
THERE ARE ALSO CONCERNS THAT
BIDEN'S UPCOMING MEETING WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL BE A
DISASTER.
TODAY THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT SAT
DOWN WITH AND BC AND TRASHED BY
IT IN THE AHEAD OF THEIR
MEETING.
>> YOU ONCE DESCRIBED
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A BRIGHT
PERSON, TALENTED.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE PRESENT
BIDEN?
>> EVEN NOW I BELIEVE THAT
FORMER U.S. PRESIDENT MR. TRUMP
IS AN EXTRAORDINARY INDIVIDUAL,
TALENTED INDIVIDUAL.
OTHERWISE YOU NOT KNOW MIKE
WOULD NOT HAVE BECOME PRESIDENT
BEAUTIES A COLORFUL INDIVIDUAL.
YOU MAY LIKE HIM OR NOT.
SOME LIKE IT, SOME DON'T LIKE
IT.
BUT THAT IS A FACT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, OF COURSE, IS
RADICALLY DIFFERENT FROM TRUMP
BECAUSE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS A
CAREER MAN.
HE SPENT VIRTUALLY HIS ENTIRE
ADULTHOOD IN POLITICS.
JUST THINK OF THE NUMBER OF
YEARS HE SPENT.
A DIFFERENT KIND OF PERSON.
IT'S MY GREAT HOPE THAT YES,
THERE IS SOME ADVANTAGES, SOME
DISADVANTAGES.
THEY WILL BE ANY IMPULSE BASED
MOVEMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Jeanine: CLEARLY THIS
UPCOMING MEETING WILL BE HIGHLY
CONTENTIOUS.
YOU'D HAVE TO WONDER IF
JOE BIDEN IS UP TO THE TASK.
AT THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA DOESN'T
CARE.
"TIME" MAGAZINE JUST PUBLISHED
AN ABSURD COVER WHERE THEY TRIED
TO MAKE BIDEN LOO